I'm gonna go for us welcome back to dark
I almost said Dark Souls blood-borne oh
my god
my baby it looks like Justin Bieber is
giving me a lil a little smooch beeps
what are you doing don't cover it up I
had such a hard time in the last episode
but I feel more confident now feel like
we're gonna do great we're not gonna die
a single time okay
all right here we go father Gus going
father gets doing daddy why are you
hitting me daddy
why daddy aah daddy oh the hell was that
we're not gonna die a single time oh oh
a single time Oh attempt number two baby
I want my health back ah then don't hurt
me please
here you go down Burt Wow out you gonna
die oh I'm going down verbal werewolf
werewolf werewolf what do I do here I
don't know what I don't know what to do
here you scary as [ __ ] okay
and it's gone ko
run - what are you get away Danny stop
it
stop I said stop daddy I said stop daddy
[Applause]
no no no I don't have any bullets oh my
god I kept trying to shoot him with that
bullet
take this poke balls then gets poked
ball just oh oh we can do it we could do
it I repeat there is a slight chance
that the poke ball could kill him come
on poke ball Charmander no doubt -
Joanna Joanna Dharma I got you
the sweet sweet daddy [ __ ] you're not
so festival now are you daddy
nice hatch brah sorry about that
the [ __ ] you throw at me you missed oh
[ __ ] that is quite the swing doesn't it
hi there little fella
how are ya you look great this morning
oh oh oh oh oh my god
shoot it shoot it I got a new outfit yay
cheap and fashionable that's my style
baby
I found some new items I can make my
weapon become fire and I think that will
damage these [ __ ] more let's let's
try it out oh damn yes that does a lot
more difference
Oh God machine gun
machine you're an [ __ ]
oh god no don't die don't die don't die
oh god that was close
[ __ ] no how dare you oh my God he's
really powerful No hey buddy how you
doing yeah they're right there
you [ __ ] face stop shooting me you're
not gonna I'm gonna push him off this is
my machine yeah now [ __ ] ha ha [ __ ]
[ __ ] they want me to jump there don't
they
dammit oh [ __ ] is that guy doing up
there hey oh oh there you want okay
stop [ __ ] no no no no 10 Marylebone yeah
how about a pretty bearable
I got how's it going for the pie here no
big deal don't shoot me and I'm dead and
I'm dead and I'm dead
now bear what the [ __ ] is this I don't
trust this for one second alright the
boss battle it's a it's a boss battle
hey I have a cocktail fate Oh God
that is some meat flaps man Jesus Christ
you know you can fix that
plastic surgery that is one scary vagina
monster
hello antidote oh god are you telling me
this guy can poison me
but he's so sexy here have this or give
me that
I don't do a lot of damage to that
[Music]
Jesus Christ
yeah that was worth it my dad yeah
[ __ ] mmm you smell good never realized
how beautiful you smell
[Music]
back
don't [ __ ] this up now kids
[Music]
that cannot be happening
oh I didn't even realize that was poison
I had that man I am dodging this [ __ ]
like a bow-wow
oh god please stop oh no line it oven
that is this is the final stage there it
is [ __ ] you in the ass [ __ ] you in yet
come on Oh for [ __ ] sake did I just
[Music]
no no it's over it's over it's over it's
so [ __ ] [ __ ] No
[Music]
you know through the wall fine fine
don't [ __ ] mind give me some [ __ ]
[Music]
so done
oh my god
[Music]
oh god no oh god no oh god no
[Music]
[ __ ] you
oh the [ __ ] is hard
ah leave it like do you want more I'm
not gonna do more otherwise I'm just
capable in a royal breast their York oh
my god what the [ __ ] are you what the
[ __ ] I can't fight a beast now get him a
fight my mom get him to beat the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] are you doing here now so
done with you